[Musique]
aujourd'hui le vol est toujours aussi
fascinant et attractif
des millions d'entre nous volent chaque
année de la même manière que d'autres
prennent le train
aujourd'hui se déplacer ainsi à travers
le ciel procure toujours ses sensations
de crainte d'excitation ses émotions
fortes qu'eux mêmes icare appuyé prouver
et en dépit de l'aspect presque banal du
vol nous sommes toujours émerveillé par
ce qui se prépare à atteindre ses
limites aller plus haut plus vite et
plus loin
la conquête du ciel l'une des plus
grandes réussites de l'humanité et il ya
peu d'endroits où il est possible de
comprendre cette fascinante aventure à
part un meeting aérien ainsi il est
possible d'assister au vol d'un avion
comme cet appareil blériot 11 qui
volaient avant la première guerre
mondiale alors que l'aviation n'en était
qu'à ses balbutiements
l'europe s'enthousiasma quand louis
blériot devient le premier homme à
franchir la manche le 25 juillet 1909
cet appareil se pilote par un système de
câble qui modifient l'incidence des
ailes par torsion inutile de préciser
que c'est un système fragile que cet
avion ne peut voler que quand les
conditions météo s'y prête
sur ce même meeting on peut aussi voir
le très récent airbus a340 600
il n'est pas seulement le plus long des
avions commerciaux mais il est aussi
capable de voler d'une traite d'europe
en australie
lui aussi utilise des câbles pour
contrôler son vol mais ces câbles
transportent des données numériques d'un
ordinateur à un autre qui permettent
d'optimiser les performances du pilotage
pour les milliers de spectateurs de ce
meeting c'est une impressionnante façon
de résumer ce que les avions sont
devenus ans précisément un siècle
il n'existe qu'une seule image du
premier volume un motorisé elle a été
prise juste après 10h35 le jeudi 17
décembre 1903 sur les dunes de sable de
kill devil à kitty hawk en caroline du
nord
orville wright est aux commandes tandis
que son frère wilber cours pour
stabiliser l de l'engin qui prend de la
vitesse
ce vol n'a duré que 12 petites secondes
et orville aveu les 36 m moins de la
moitié de la longueur de l'airbus mais
ils ont réalisé le point de départ
d'événements et d'innovation qui nous
emmène directement à l'airbus
le flyer tel qu'il l'avait baptisé est
l'aboutissement de siècle de tentatives
menées par les prédécesseurs des frères
wright
c'est leur obstination proche de
l'obsession qui a permis aux deux frères
de réussir
ils sont arrivés à ce résultat en
réalisant de nombreuses expériences sur
la manière de contrôler un aéroplane
dans les trois dimensions
ainsi ils ont rapidement compris que la
meilleure manière d'effectuer un virage
en avion et de lui faire faire une
rotation autour de son axe longitudinal
mais les frères wright était si secret
sur leur projet que celui ci mis
longtemps à se développer ainsi lorsque
le projet ses ventes à nombreux furent
ceux qui demeurèrent sceptiques
[Musique]
personne ne peut nier que la france a
été le creuset de l'aviation en europe
à un groupe d'individus issus du monde
du spectacle des scientifiques des
ingénieurs et de riches hommes
d'affaires dépenses r&d fortune pour
devenir les premiers hommes volants
[Musique]
bien après que les frères a été réussi
leur premier vol les aviateurs en europe
cherchait encore à défier la gravité
mais doucement ils ont réinventé l'avion
est suivie les ryd dans le ciel
[Musique]
un des plus remarquables de ces
aviateurs européen était un franco
brésilien alberto santos dur
en
novembre 1906 son impressionnante
machine baptisée 14 bis vola sur une
distance de plus de 200 m en 21 une
seconde et demie c'était un des tout
premier vol motorisé à tester et cet
exploit enthousiasma le continent tout
entier
les aviateurs européen continuèrent
courageusement leur expérimentation
tandis que les exploits des frères
wright était oublié progressivement en
france les frères voisins et c'est hier
un grand nombre de formules d'aéroplan
généralement à l'instigation de leur
client en janvier 1908 en riz farman
effectua le premier kilomètre en circuit
en 28 secondes et gagner ainsi le prix
de 50 mille francs promis
[Musique]
la venue en 1908 de wilbur wright en
europe donnera un nouvel élan à
l'aviation en résolvant quelques
problèmes fondamentaux
les wright avait développé un système de
gauchissement de la voilure pour
permettre le contrôle latéral une
solution qui avait été oubliée par les
aviateurs européen
en septembre 1908 wilber effectua une
importante série de démonstrations aux
hunaudières près du mans
une véritable foule assistent à ces vols
qui culminèrent le 21 septembre
lorsqu'il réussit un vol de plus d'une
heure et demie
[Musique]
bien sur les rails étaient là pour
vendre leurs avions et les brevets de
leur invention mais il démontre r la
large avance technique qu'ils avaient
atteint
en angleterre un citoyen américain
samuel f cody tenta de susciter
l'intérêt des militaires pour son avion
selon les standards de 1908 avec son
envergure de 17 m son engin fut surnommé
la cathédrale
le des dents des militaires pour
l'aviation changea en juillet 1909
deux hommes tentaient de traverser la
manche tous deux avaient leurs chances
d'y arriver mais le sort décide a qu'un
seul entreraient dans l'histoire louis
blériot
traverser la manche était alors
considérée comme une étape décisive pour
l'aviation
en conséquence le daily mail offrait un
prix de 1000 livres sterling au premier
aviateur qui réussirent est cet exploit
deux hommes à relever le défi hubert
latham et louis blériot latham fut le
premier à tenter sa chance à bord d'un
monoplan antoine est propulsé par un
moteur de 25 chevaux
sur chacune des deux côtes les
spectateurs étaient nombreux pour
assister à cette tentative historique
[Musique]
la femme avait volé déjà une dizaine de
kilomètres lorsque son moteur c'est da
ilha mairie tant bien que mal et furent
amenés à calais sur un navire d'escort
sûr de lui il déclara qu'il resterait
sur un nouvel avion
observant tout ceci appuyé sur ses
béquilles puisqu'il s'était brûlé les
jambes dans un crash se tenait louis
blériot et il était alors presque ruiné
toute sa fortune et celle de sa femme
avaient été dépensés dans sa quête de
l'aviation mais un répit de dernière
minute lui permis d'engager un avion
qu'il avait conçu le blériot 11
le dimanche 25 juillet blériot estima
que les conditions étaient idéales pour
sa tentative
à l'aube ils descola alors que sa femme
dormait encore
37 minutes plus tard il se posait non
loin du château de douvres
bien peu de personnes s'aperçurent qu'il
fut à deux doigts d'échouer
à quelques encablures des falaises
blanches de douvres les rafales de vent
firent dérivés sont fragiles avion vers
le nord pendant une dizaine de minutes
il fut complètement perdu puis il
aperçut trois navires qui se dirigeait
vraisemblablement vers douvres et il
suivi leur direction
[Musique]
il distingua de loin le drapeau français
qu'un de ses amis brandissait sur le
lieu choisi de l'atterrissage
luttant contre les vents dominants ils
se posent a violemment et endommagea
sévèrement son avion mais il était
indemne et prouve est entré dans la
légende aujourd'hui quelques exemplaires
de son avion sont encore en état de vol
ces répliques fidèles sont très fragiles
et très difficile à piloter
[Musique]
la collection shuttleworth sur
l'aérodrome de warden au nord de londres
possède quelques magnifiques exemplaires
de ces avions d'avant la première guerre
mondiale le blériot 11 et le plus vieil
avion du monde et ils veulent très
rarement se contentant de survoler la
piste de l'aérodrome sept autres
exemplaires appartient aux pilotes de
ligne mikael karlsson bien qu'il soit
d'un modèle plus récent équipé d'un
moteur plus puissant il est très proche
de celui utilisé par louis blériot
le vol de blériot n'a duré que trente
sept minutes mais son caractère épique
frappe à l'imaginaire du grand public
pour les frères wright la traversée de
la manche semblait n'avoir aucun intérêt
il avait effectué des vols largement
supérieur à la performance de blériot
mais ils se discréditent est presque en
sous-estimant la signification de cet
exploit pour l'europe et l'enthousiasmé
généré par toute la publicité faite
autour de cet événement
[Musique]
l'euphorie fut à son comble quatre
semaines plus tard lorsque la crème des
aviateurs européens se rencontrèrent
pour le meeting aérien de l'histoire la
grande semaine aéronautique de reims le
seul représentant des usa et et glenn
curtiss pratiquement inconnu jusqu alors
en europe mais à la réputation bien
établie dans son pays comme constructeur
de moteurs
la foule se pressera en masse pour
assister aux exploits des aviateurs qui
s'affrontaient dans des compétitions
d'altitude de distance et même de
transport de passagers
[Musique]
mais le prix le plus prestigieux était
la coupe international d'aviation
célèbre sous le nom de coupe gordon
bennett
[Musique]
glenn curtiss l'emporta de six petites
secondes sur blériot
en éprouvant leur machine en compétition
les aviateurs démontrer à quel point
l'aviation avaient progressé depuis
kitty hawk six ans plus tôt
les années suivantes de nombreux
événements rythmèrent le développement
de l'aviation en premier les défis de
distancer d'altitude permirent de
franchir un à un les différents
obstacles naturels en europe
ceci fut facilitée par les évolutions
importantes que les avions subir
en 1913 adolphe pégoud étonna le monde
entier en effectuant un vol sur le dos
de 150 mètres et redressant ensuite son
avion
élan chaîne à part le tout premier
looping de l'histoire exploit considéré
alors comme au delà des capacités
physiques du maire
derrière l'aspect spectaculaire de ces
essais d'hiver se cachait la volonté
d'outrepasser les limites de la machine
et de son pilote
cette même année il avait travaillé avec
louis blériot sur un système pour
permettre aux avions d'atterrir sur le
pont d'un navire en mer composé d'une
grosse pour saisir les câbles d'arrêt
il devient aussi le premier pilote à
faire usage d'un parachute depuis un
avion après avoir atterri il observa son
avion évolué de lui-même avant de
s'écraser ce qui lui donna l'idée de la
boucle
mais nous étions en 1913 et l'europe se
dirigeait alors vers la guerre une
guerre dans laquelle l'aviation allait
prendre son ampleur
de nombreux pays cherchait à regagner le
temps perdu l'angleterre n'étant pas en
reste
une de ses premières créations fut un
triple ans qui fut un des premiers à
faire usage de parties mobiles les
ailerons ceci permettait un meilleur
contrôle en roulis que le gauchissement
de l'ale à tel point que leur usage fut
standard sur les avions des 90 années
suivantes en 1913 il conçut un avion
parfaitement réussi le 500 call
en 1913 il conçut un avion parfaitement
réussie l'avro 504 des milliers
d'exemplaires en furent construits et
les modèles les plus tardifs voler
encore dans les années 30 un nombre
incalculable d'aviateur découvrir le vol
aux commandes d'un avro 504 en 1913 le
504 équipe ait deux corps aérien promis
à un grand avenir le royal flying corse
et le royal naval air service
les objectifs initiaux ont été de
n'avoir qu'une seule arme aérienne mais
l'amirauté était déterminé à conserver
son pouvoir sur toutes les affaires
navale conscient que la reconnaissance
aérienne pouvait à croire l'efficacité
de ces navires elle créa une première
escadrille qui finit par devenir un
corps à part entière qui opérait en
totale indépendance vis-à-vis du rfc
la guerre semblait alors inévitable
l'angleterre était déterminé à ne pas
perdre de temps et l'entraînement
d'aviateur devint une priorité
comparé à aujourd'hui cette formation
était bien rudimentaire plus orienté sur
la pratique que sur l'aspect théorique
si le pilote kahn est arrivé à atterrir
en un seul morceau il avait toutes ses
chances pour le brevet
au déclenchement du conflit en plein été
1914 le rfc possédait 63 avions 146
officiers et 1097 hommes de troupe
le rns 50 avions 130 officiers et 700
hommes son rôle consistait à la défense
de l'angleterre et de ses côtes
les tensions en europe à tenir leur
point de rupture le 28 juin 1914 lorsque
l'archiduc austro-hongrois
françois-ferdinand fut assassiné à
sarajevo
cet assassinat précipite à l'europe dans
la guerre un jeu d'alliances qui se
devait dissuasif entraîna les pays les
uns contre les autres d'un côté
l'allemagne et l'autriche hongrie de
l'autre la france la grande bretagne et
la russie
le point d'orgue arriva le 4 août
l'allemagne envahissant la belgique dont
la neutralité était pourtant garanti par
un traité signé par la france
l'angleterre et l'allemagne mais dont le
kaiser fille bien peu de cas de fait ils
plongent à l'europe dans une période des
plus sanglantes de son histoire une
guerre dans les participants payèrent le
prix durement et même longtemps après
que la peine fut revenu quatre ans plus
tard
les plantes attaque allemand portait sur
les âges des forces très mobiles pour
une attaque éclair de la france à
travers la belgique dont les défenses
étaient faibles après la france vaincue
l'armée allemande devaient embarquer
dans des trains est reporté son attaque
sur le front est contre la russie
le plan allemand fut à deux doigts de
réussir au début du mois de septembre
l'armée allemande avait avancée jusqu'à
la marne au nord de paris et la capitale
semblait être condamné l'armée française
déterminée à sauver paris concentre à
tout ce qu'elle pouvait trouver comme
combattants disponibles et les conduisit
avec les célèbres taxis de la marne sur
le front où ils furent nombreux à périr
mais ils résistèrent suffisamment pour
permettre l'arrivée de renforts anglais
pour le moment l'avancée des troupes
allemandes été jugulée
des aviateurs français et anglais
découvrir que les troupes allemandes
tentaient d'attaquer les flancs des
troupes françaises les forces alliées
parvinrent à les contenir
ce fut un moment décisif dans
l'évolution de l'armée aérienne avant la
guerre les états majors ne pouvait avoir
une vision claire de l'utilité des
aéronefs à ce moment il devint évident
qu'il pouvait devenir indispensable dans
l'observation et la reconnaissance
[Musique]
l'artillerie avait grand besoin de ces
auxiliaires et les puisque les
observations des aviateurs permettait
d'ajuster la précision des tirs ont
conçu donc des avions spécifique pour
ces missions
le vickers gones buzz se distingua dans
ce rôle l'observateur situé devant le
pilote disposer d'un champ de vision
exceptionnelle puisque le moteur était
situé à l'arrière du fuselage
[Musique]
les progrès de la radio télégraphie sans
fil signifiait que les informations
pouvaient parvenir aux batteries
d'artillerie sans que les avions n'est
besoin de se poser mais la guerre
terrestre était dans une impasse en mer
les flottes puissantes des belligérants
étaient restés dans leur port d'attache
elle était trop précieuse pour les
risques et en pleine mer
puisque les troupes au sol étaient
enterrés dans les tranchées dans la boue
et le froid la guerre dans les airs
ressembler à une fantastique aventure
comparé à la misère des autres soldats
la réalité était toutefois fort
différentes les avions se révélèrent si
efficaces dans leur rôle d'observation
que les aviateurs commencèrent
rapidement à se combattre les uns les
autres rapidement les avions furent
équipés de mitrailleuses terriblement
efficace pour descendre les autres
appareils la guerre aérienne prenait
alors une nouvelle tournure la conquête
du contrôle du ciel
les allemands firent une avancée
remarquable avec le monoplan fokker e3
qui a paru sur le front en juillet 1915
ses mitrailleuses et est synchronisé
pour pouvoir tirer à travers le chant de
l'hélice le pilote n'avait qu'à viser
son adversaire avec son avion pour
effectuer un tir efficace
une autre spécificité du fokker était sa
gouverne de profondeur monobloc bien que
les chasseurs actuel possède tous cette
spécificité il fallut alors près de 30
ans avant que ses caractéristiques
réapparaissent cette fois encore sur un
chasseur allemand le m 262 le premier
chasseur à réaction opérationnel
les pilotes alliés étaient terriblement
vulnérables face à ce qu'ils appelaient
le fléau de fokker en réaction les
constructeurs alliés conte sur de
nouveaux chasseurs ainsi apparurent les
nieuport l'espad et le s5
ce dernier fut construit spécifiquement
comme chasseur un rôle qui tend à
merveille
il était extrêmement solide et puissant
presque deux fois plus rapide que les
avions de 1914 il était aussi une
plateforme de tir stable et puissante
armé d'une mitrailleuse vickers
synchronisée et d'une lewis monter au
dessus d'elle
le s5 ainsi que le spad vii permis aux
alliés de reprendre la supériorité
aérienne sur les allemands
[Musique]
le s5 rejoigne au front le saut
puisses-tu pris plein les ailes cours du
triple end lui permettait des virages
très rapides et un taux de montée
extraordinaire à peu près 150
exemplaires furent construits et presque
tous furent livrés aux escadrille du r n
as en france qui connurent de grands
succès une unité l'escadrille b du 10e
squadrons remporté à 87 victoires entre
mai et juillet 1917
les pilotes allemands furent si
impressionné qu'il réclame r à leur tour
un triple en le résultat fut le
légendaire fokker dr1 triplant qui
s'avéra être un chasseur redoutable
systématiquement mortelle contre des
avions plus lent que lui comme les
avions de reconnaissance
en juillet 1917 un nouveau chasseur
arrivés en nombre et qui fut avec le
fokker 17 et le spath 13 l'un des tous
meilleurs chasseurs de la guerre le seul
puisque hamel
il a été appelé le chameau à cause des
deux bosses qui entouraient ses
mitrailleuses
s'il se révélait difficile à piloter
voire dangereux entre les mains d'un
pilote inexpérimenté le camel était
grâce à sa maniabilité un chasseur
exceptionnel
[Musique]
les pilotes de kamel enregistrèrent plus
de 3000 victoires aériennes plus que
n'importe quel autre avion
alors que les premières doctrine de
combat aérien commencé à apparaître les
pilotes apprenait sur le tas les
tactiques les plus importantes comme
préféré engager le combat à une altitude
supérieure de celle de l'adversaire si
possible en conservant le soleil
derrière soi en plongeant dans la queue
de sa cible
tournoyant dans le ciel les pilotes
effectuer leur ballet mortel jour après
jour pour le public à l'arrière les
pilotes et aide les chevaliers de l'air
héros d'un combat noble d'hommes à
la réalité était bien éloigné de ses
comportements de jane que mène le combat
aérien ap les dogues fight combat
tournoyant était en effet comme un
combat de chiens chaotique et vicieux le
ciel pouvait être empli de machines
s'affrontant à un moment et l'instant
d'après laisser la place à un ciel bleu
est clair il n'y avait pas de parachute
et le pilote vaincu s'il n'avait pas été
tuées directement plongé vers le sol
dans un grand panache de fumée noire son
avion brûlant autour de lui l'espérance
de vie des pilotes au front n'excède pas
quelques semaines en moyenne
mais ce n'était pas ce que le public et
les politiciens voulaient en temps les
exploits des aviateurs devait briller
pour faire oublier la noirceur de la
guerre
la légende s'établit des deux côtés du
front un pilote qui obtenait cinq
victoires recevait le titre d'as lors
non devinrent familier nungesser guînes
mr mcc et john bowman hoc sud est fausse
mais le plus célèbre et le plus respecté
de tous si le baron rouge manfred von
richthofen pour lui comme pour un grand
nombre d'as il ne vit pas la fin de la
guerre a battu en avril 1918
il y avait un autre aspect de la guerre
aérienne - de l'amour ou aux yeux du
public - 0 hic les bombardiers qui
pouvait atteindre des villes à des
centaines de kilomètres du front
l'angleterre avait déjà goûté à ce type
de guerre quand les dirigeable zeppelin
avaient attaqué londres et d'autres
villes anglaises en décembre 1914 et
souvent de nuit le choc pour la
population releva deloutre âge car
prévisible l'angleterre n'avait pas de
chasseurs pour protéger son territoire
ce besoin d'une défense coordonnée
contre les attaques adverses conduisit à
la formation de la force aérienne
britannique la royal air force le 1er
avril 1918 la première armée aérienne
indépendante au monde
avec 27 mille officiers 260 mille hommes
de troupe ses 3300 avions répartis en
150 squadrons opérationnel la royal air
force devenait une armée à part entière
nombreuses et très bien équipée
quelques-uns de ses avions étaient les
meilleurs de leurs catégories telles que
le bristol fighter lequel était
construit en angleterre essentiellement
par des entreprises privées
les progrès fulgurants les avions
volaient deux fois plus haut est deux
fois plus vite qu'au début de la guerre
et les moteurs était devenue efficace et
fiable
il devint alors possible de construire
des avions gigantesque comme le vickers
vimy qui pouvait porter la guerre jusque
dans les villes ennemies
levine y avait un équipage de quatre
hommes et transportaient 11 cents kilos
de bombes ces moteurs rolls royce eagle
lui autorisait une autonomie de 11
heures de vol
les bombardiers de ce type constituent l
épine dorsale de la flotte de bombardier
de la royal air force jusqu'au début des
années 30 et à la fin de la guerre ils
permirent d'explorer de nouvelles
fonctions civiles comme le transport de
passagers et de fret
ap travers le monde
pendant les quinze années qui séparent r
le miracle de tio2 la fin de la première
guerre mondiale l'avion était devenue
une arme indispensable
les rôles de supériorité aérienne
l'importance du bombardement de la
reconnaissance et du transport avaient
tous été essayées est rendu à un point
tel que depuis ce moment-là le contrôle
du ciel est devenu un objectif
prioritaire pour toutes les guerres du
futur
à la suite de l'armistice de 1918 une
drastique réduction des forces armées
s'engagea
le monde entier étaient là de cette
guerre son coût humain avait été bien
trop élevée sans oublier que ce premier
conflit de l'ère industrielle avait mis
à mal l'économie de nombreux pays les
avions étaient trop chers à fabriquer le
développement de l'aviation militaire se
ralentit voire se stoppe a littéralement
on assista alors l'émergence d'une
aviation civile et commerciale en 1909
la manche avait été le premier grand
obstacle naturel à être franchie
en 1919 c'est vers l'atlantique que tous
les regards se tournaient
le premier vol transatlantique fut
effectuée le 14 juin 1919
quand deux aviateurs de la royal air
force john hancock et arthur bronn
traversèrent l'océan du groenland à
l'irlande aborda vigueur vimy en
16h28
[Musique]
l'avion avait relié deux continents mais
un autre grand paris subsistait voler
vers le continent le plus éloigné
l'australie
[Musique]
en 1919 ceux ci paraissait impossible
aucun avion n'a vait l'autonomie
nécessaire pour traverser le pacifique
au départ de la côte ouest des usa la
solution alternative était de traverser
l'europe le moyen-orient et l'asie du
sud est ce qui signifiait survolé les
zones les plus inhospitalières de la
planète
les volontaires ne manquait pourtant pas
surtout lorsque le gouvernement
australien annonce sac un prix de dix
mille livres seraient attribués au
vainqueur
le 12 novembre 1919 deux frères ross et
qui smith s'envolèrent de oslo à bord
d'un mini
les matricules ation de leur avion était
gea ou fut interprétée comme god it's
all force d'y eux nous aide tous et ils
eurent bien besoin de cette aide civile
il embarque à des pièces détachées afin
de faire face à toutes les éventualités
de panne même si chaque kilo
supplémentaire gréve aient leur chance
de réussite
est en effet le vol ne se déroula pas
sans incidents notamment une rupture de
la roulette de que sur un terrain mal
préparés en malaisie pièce pour laquelle
il n'avait évidemment pas de rechange et
qu'il fallu refaire entièrement
[Musique]
finalement après 28 jours de vol et à la
limite de la panne sèche il se posèrent
triomphalement à darwin
[Musique]
neuf années plus tard bertling leur
suivi la même route à bord de son avro à
vianne il mis quinze jours pour
accomplir ce périple ce qui était un
exploit eu égard à l'endurance
l'autonomie et la vitesse de son avion
tout au long de ces années d'entre deux
guerres les frontières du vol fut
repoussée par des hommes dont le seul
but était de voler plus haut plus loin
et plus vite
[Musique]
des avions furent spécialement construit
pour établir de nouveaux records le plus
célèbre d'entre eux fut le spirit of
saint louis avec lequel charles
lindbergh accompli l'exploit de
traverser l'atlantique en solitaire en
mai 1927
et plus les records tombent et plus le
transport de passagers prenaient de
l'ampleur
les hydravions ont été utilisés aussi
bien le long des routes civils que
militaires car il offrait le plus de
souplesse pour le transport des
passagers et du fret sur des longues
distances en 1929 ses avions avaient
atteint des tailles gigantesques
le dornier des os x fut l'un des plus
énormes avec une envergure de 52 mètres
une longueur de 45 m et une hauteur de
dix mètres il était si gros que les
passagers étaient invités à se déplacer
d'un côté à l'autre lors des virages
pour l'aider à tourner
l'aménagement intérieur et les services
apportent du des os x et est identique à
ceux des paquebots de croisières
transatlantiques
plusieurs cabines sur le pont principal
accueillait les passagers sur trente
deux fauteuils double et deux simples
tandis que le cockpit la cabine du
commandant les postes du navigateur du
mécanicien navigant et du radio se
trouvaient sur le pont supérieur le fret
et le carburant étaient stockés au pont
inférieur
[Musique]
dans le même temps des compagnies
aériennes commencèrent à proposer des
vols réguliers le voyage aérien effectué
sa première démocratisation en 1930 le
rendent les pages hp 42 entré au service
des impérial airways pour desservir les
zones les plus éloignées de l'empiré
britannique
[Musique]
simultanément juncker introduisez en
allemagne son nouvel appareil de
transport l'oeil ou 52
la tante ue comme on l'appelait
affectueusement trouve à plus tard sa
vocation de transport militaire
[Musique]
au déclenchement de la guerre civile
espagnole l'eiu 52 furent utilisés pour
ravitailler l'armée de franco depuis
l'afrique du nord c'est à ce moment que
l' avantage face à des républicains aux
nationalistes
il y eut de nombreuses autres occasions
où l'oeil ou 52 pris une part cruciale
au conflit spécialement lorsqu on lui
confia le rôle de transporter des
troupes de parachutistes
[Musique]
dans les années 20 et au début de la
décennie suivante le manque de commandes
militaires forcé les constructeurs à
trouver d'autres marchés pour survivre
l'aviation légère sportives et de
loisirs permis à ces entreprises de
mettre leurs compétences au profit d'
avion plus petit et moins cher
certains comme le de havilland tiger
moth furent initialement construits
comme des avions d'entraînement
militaire puis vendues à des pilotes
privés la production du taillan mars
atteignait huit mille exemplaires dont
un grand nombre continue à voler encore
de nos jours
[Musique]
les compétitions aérienne pris une telle
ampleur que des avions spécialisés de
vars indispensable déléguant monoplan
telles que le maïs hawk speed 6 furent
ainsi mise au point
[Musique]
de telles compétitions rôle hier des
continents comme la course mark
robertson en 1934 entre l'angleterre et
l'australie qui furent emportés par le
drh comme est spécialement conçu pour
elle
[Musique]
mais le plus important et le plus fameux
de ces concours internationaux puis la
coupe schneider en 1931 elle fut
définitivement remporté par l'angleterre
qui l'emportait pour la troisième fois
consécutive l'équipe de pilotes de la
royal air force utilisait un hydravion
supermarine est 6b qui atteint la
vitesse de 650 kilomètres heure
établissant au passage un record du
monde de vitesse
certains s'inquiétaient que ses avions
de course et des vitesses supérieures à
celles des plus rapides chasseurs de
l'époque
car depuis le début des années 30 les
bruits de conflits devenait sans cesse
plus fort en europe conséquence de
l'arrivée au pouvoir des nazis en
allemagne où adolf hitler réarmer son
pays intensivement bien que le traité de
versailles signé en 1919 lui interdisent
de posséder une force aérienne
l'allemagne entraînait des pilotes et
construisaient des avions militaires
parmi deux nouveaux monoplan très rapide
se trouvait le messerschmitt bf 109 qui
effectua son premier vol en mai 1935
bien que le bf 109 devint une des icônes
de la bataille d'angleterre il combattit
sur tous les fronts de la russie à
l'afrique du nord et hommage à sa
conception il restait encore l'avion de
prédilection des as de la luftwaffe à la
fin du conflit alors même que de
nouveaux appareils étaient apparues
extrêmement manoeuvrable et plus rapide
que ses contemporains lors de sa mise en
service le sang neuf et est aussi mieux
armée avec ses mitrailleuses et ses
canons
on estime que près de 35000 bf 109 fut
reconstruit faisant de cet avion le
deuxième appareil le plus produit de
l'histoire de l'aviation
parallèlement à ces nouveaux chasseurs
l'allemagne s'était engagée dans la
production de bombardier le heinkel 111
en étant l'archétype
bombardier bimoteur moyens l'efficacité
du rein qu'elle était confirmée par ses
missions pendant la guerre en espagne
mais sa vulnérabilité contre les
chasseurs anglais pendant la bataille
d'angleterre dévoilèrent son manque
d'armement défensif
l'ajout de membres d'équipage et d'armes
supplémentaires ne firent que l'alourdir
le rendent encore plus lent et donc plus
vulnérables
1935 est une des années charnières de
l'histoire de l'aviation
certains avions considéré comme des
étapes importantes de cette histoire
firent leurs débuts cette année-là en
mars 1935 le compte céli gâteuse bby
catalina fit son tout premier vol son
autonomie lui permettait des vols de
plus de 20 heures
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale les
catalina furent d'une très grande
efficacité dans la reconnaissance
maritime et le sauvetage en raison de
son évidente utilité il fut construit
plus de catalina coach à notre hydravion
[Musique]
en
juillet 1935 apparu le b 17 flying
fortress 2 boeing
l'image de la forteresse volante et pour
l'éternité associés aux images des
armadas aérienne de la 8ème air force
qui bombardèrent l'allemagne à partir de
1942 pourtant ces premiers combats
eurent lieu au sein même de la royal air
force
les premiers modèles étaient vulnérables
aux attaques frontales l'avant de
l'avion étant dépourvue d'armement
ceci fut progressivement améliorée et
lorsque la variante b 17 g arriva en
service elle possédait un total de
treize mitrailleuses de 12 7 aujourd'hui
la légende du b 17 est bien établie
pourtant l'avion failli ne jamais entrer
en service lorsque le prototype s'écrasa
au cours d'un vol d'évaluation alors
qu'il était en compétition avec un
prototype équivalent construit par
douglas
mais c'est avec un avion de transport
que douglas pose un jalon important dans
l'histoire de l'aviation le dc3 fit son
premier vol en 1935 et joue un rôle
primordial dans l'évolution des lignes
aériennes civiles
[Musique]
lorsque la guerre éclata les avions
civils furent réquisitionnés directement
sur les chaînes de production
on les dota2 plus grande porte cargo et
ils reçurent une peinture de camouflage
avant d'être envoyé au combat le dc3
bientôt universellement connu comme le
dakota prouva rapidement ses grandes
qualités ils pouvaient opérer depuis les
pistes est plus difficile même surchargé
de troupes ou de matériel
au final le dakota est considérée comme
l'une des armes les plus importantes du
conflit dont l'influent ce fut
particulièrement sensible à partir du
moment où les alliés sont passés à
l'offensive
la capacité de l'appareil à opérer
depuis des pistes rapidement improvisé
proche du front a permis aux troupes de
première ligne d'être rapidement
régulièrement approvisionné pour appuyer
leur progression
[Musique]
en angleterre le développement de
nouveaux avions avaient pris du retard
par rapport aux autres pays d'europe
mais lorsque la guerre de 21 évitables
un programme destiné à rééquiper la
royal air force de matériel moderne fut
engagée
pendant des années le bombardier fait
considérer comme l' arme de terreur
définitive
dans une certaine mesure la royal air
force avaient utilisé les capacités des
bombardiers pour maintenir l'ordre dans
ses colonies
mais pas s'y fier des tribus
montagnardes et combattre dans une
guerre totale en europe sont
singulièrement différent mais ceci ne
fut pas clairement reconnu par les états
majors
[Musique]
l'accent fut porté sur l'amélioration
des chasseurs de défense c'est quand le
rocker week-end effectua son premier vol
en novembre 1935 il devint clair qu'une
nouvelle époque commencer
bien que le week-end soit un monoplan la
technique de construction employés
étaient similaires à celles utilisées
pour les biplans
[Musique]
bien que considérés comme moins de
l'amour que le spitfire le week-end
était réellement fiable les balles
pouvait le traverser et tant qu'elle ne
touchait aucune partie vitale l'avion
pouvait ramener son pilote
[Musique]
il
et pourtant depuis son premier vol en
1936 c'est le spitfire qui monopolisa
l'attention
cet avion est le résultat de
l'expérience obtenue par l'ingénieur
reginald mitchell avec le super marine
est 6b vainqueur de la coupe schneider
bien qu'il soit un avion
particulièrement beau le spitz était
compliqué à construire et bien que les
rubriques n étaient plus nombreux à
combattre lors de la bataille
d'angleterre plus de 20000 spitfire ont
été construits jusqu'en 1947
[Musique]
les premiers modèles étaient équipés de
moteurs rolls-royce merlin les versions
plus tardives ont reçu un moteur griffon
beaucoup plus puissants et lui aussi
construits par rolls royce les pilotes
adorent et le spi est une passion qui
perdure encore aujourd'hui le spi tête
un avion dans lequel on ne s'assoit pas
tout simplement mais avec lequel on fait
corps pour les puristes les premiers
spitz à moteur merlin avec leurs lignes
élégantes et leur plus petite taille
sont toujours très appréciés et
considérés comme les speed ultime
[Musique]
mais
l'arrivée du vickers wellington
représente à une amélioration notable
bien que limitée de la puissance de
bombardements de la royal air force
comme le speak now wellington était un
avion à la structure complexe formé de
longerons entrecroisées ce qui
permettait une conception à la fois
robuste et légère le wellington était
destiné à former l'ossature du royal air
force bombers commandes pour les
premières années du conflit il fut en
réalité la seule arme à ce moment là
disponibles pour frapper l'ennemi il y
avait beaucoup de problèmes à surmonter
et telles que la navigation ou la
précision de visée mais la seule
capacité au wellington à pouvoir
atteindre l'allemagne de nuit et
bombarder ces villes mis à bas la
réputation d'un vulnérabilité auto
proclamée par les nazis
[Musique]
le déclenchement des hostilités en
septembre 1939 fut l'ouverture d'une
nouvelle époque pour la puissance
aérienne de nombreuses théories avait
émergé lors de l'entre-deux-guerres les
six années qui ont suivi ont apporté
quelques réponses définitives
la guerre éclair menée par les allemands
avaient démontré l'efficacité de
l'aviation d'attac tactique la
coordination des forces aériennes et des
blindés furent mortels et heyvaert à
bout des armées de pologne des pays-bas
et de la belgique pauvrement armés et
finalement de la france
mais une fois arrivés sur les côtes
françaises la luftwaffe découvrit
qu'elle n'était pas assez équipés pour
une guerre et aériennes stratégiques
[Musique]
ces chasseurs n'avaient qu'une autonomie
limitée ce qui réduisait la protection
qu'ils pouvaient fournir aux bombardiers
de même les bombardiers étaient tous des
engins de taille moyenne et devaient se
réunir en très large formation pour
pouvoir constituer une flotte capable
d'infliger des dommages significatifs à
l'ennemi
et contre eux se dressait une force bien
entraînées et équipées et surtout
superbement motivé le fighter commandes
de la royal air force depuis leur
aérodrome les pilotes de la royal air
force enchaînait quatre ou cinq sorties
voire plus au cours d'une seule journée
les équipages de la louve à feu ne
pouvait au mieux en faire que deux par
jour parce qu'elle combattait au dessus
de l'angleterre la royal air force
multiplier la puissance de ses forces
mais c'est l'intégration dans la défense
de l'angleterre d'une nouvelle
technologie de concert avec les
chasseurs les observateurs qui a fait
pencher la balance le radar
et il pouvait donner des indications
simples sur la taille et la direction
des formations aériennes qui passaient
les côtes françaises le corps des
observateurs confirmé ces données
visuellement toutes les informations
étaient centralisées et analysés pour
que le commandant du fighter command &
young loading puisse ordonner aux
chasseurs de décoller en quantité
suffisante pour contrer la menace
[Musique]
la luftwaffe débute à ce qui devait plus
tard s'appelait la bataille d'angleterre
en bombardant les bases des chasseurs et
les radars de la côte sud
des vagues de bombardier les pylônes
airs tandis que les messerschmitt
patrouillaient au dessus en attendant
les chasseurs anglais
les attaques ne durait qu'une poignée de
minutes mais les destructions engendrées
affaiblissait les défense britannique
[Musique]
jour après jour les pilotes de la royal
air force se tenait prêt à décoller dès
l'aube lorsque le crépuscule arrivait il
était rare qu'il n'ait pas effectué une
ou plusieurs missions épuisante
mais c'est courageux pilote montant les
superbes américaine et spitfire étaient
trop peu nombreux pour endiguer
totalement ses attaques les réparations
des aérodromes bombardé même rapidement
effectué limiter le nombre de chasseurs
immédiatement disponible la royal air
force était en train de perdre la
bataille
c'est alors que les événements
atteignait un point critique qu'un
événement dramatique sur 20 sur l'ordre
direct de gicleurs la luftwaffe porte à
son offensive non plus sur les
installations militaires mais sur les
sites et anglaise
ces attaques aussi déplaisante furent
telles les serres un petit répit aux
facteurs commandes qui prit son second
souffle et une toute nouvelle vigueur
[Musique]
le sort de la bataille pencha alors en
faveur de la royal air force sans avoir
obtenu la supériorité aérienne
l'allemagne ne pouvait en aucun cas
envisager un débarquement en angleterre
le paroxysme des combats fuite atteint
lors des deux premières semaines de
septembre 1940 lorsque vague après vague
la luftwaffe attaque à londres
[Musique]
mais elle le fit au prix de pertes
inacceptable
en octobre la bataille était
virtuellement terminé et même si les
raids ont continué tout l'hiver suivant
l'angleterre avait remporté la toute
première bataille stratégiquement
significative en combattant uniquement
avec ses avions
[Musique]
tandis que la bataille d'angleterre
continuer pendant l'automne 1940 une
nouvelle forme de puissance aérienne fut
employée contre la flotte italienne le
porte avions
la royal navy avait reconnu dès la
première guerre mondiale le potentiel
offensif des avions lorsqu'elle avait
lancé des attaques contre les hangars
des dirigeables et plat
pendant les années qui ont précédé la
seconde guerre mondiale les marines
américaine et britannique avaient
développé des navires porte avions
pensant qu'ils étaient la meilleure
solution pour projeter une force
aérienne à longue distance
le vix novembre 1940 20 biplan ferrer
swordfish décollé du porte-avions hms
invincible et attaquer la flotte
italienne dans le port de tarente au sud
de l'italie
[Musique]
même si le soir fiche était alors
considérée comme dépassée il prouva être
une arme dévastatrice
en volant à moins de 50 pieds les soirs
fiches sont passés sous les défenses
antiaériennes et ont réussi à larguer
leurs bombes et leurs torpilles
[Musique]
la flotte italienne l'une des plus
importantes du monde fut décimée et
n'inquiètent a plus personne par la
suite
la puissance des forces aéronavales
étant ainsi prouver et elle prit même de
l'importance au cours des combats
suivants
[Musique]
la marine impériale japonaise avait en
effet observer les leçons de tarente
avec beaucoup d'intérêt
le 7 décembre 1941 les avions de la
marine japonaise lancé depuis plusieurs
porte-avions attaque la flotte
américaine à pearl harbor
[Musique]
ce fut un désastre pour les américains
qui pensaient que l'atlantique et le
pacifique
constituée dé protection naturelle
contre les attaques adverses
[Musique]
l' attaque de pearl harbour entraîna les
usa dans cette guerre avec leurs
capacités industrielles immense le sort
des armes pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale allait être profondément
modifiée et ce n'était qu'une question
de temps
la solution pour combattre dans le
pacifique était de construire des porte
avions
us navy était déjà prête à employer des
avions spécialement conçu pour la
rigueur des opérations aéronavales
le gruman wild cat est typique de cette
première génération d'avions puissant
qui se sont révélés décisifs pendant ces
combats dans l'océan pacifique
même si le zéro japonais s'est révélé
bien plus manoeuvrant le wildcat était
plus rapide en piqué possédait un
blindage plus efficaces et des armes
d'un calibre supérieur capable de
pulvériser les fragiles avions japonais
plus tard dans cette conquête du
pacifique la puissance de l'aéronavale
américaine fut renforcée par l'arrivée
du vote corsaire initialement le
corsaire se révèle décevant par sa
faible visibilité et par la propension
qu'il avait de rebondir à l'atterrissage
ce qui le rendait incompatible avec les
appontages sur les porte-avions
mais une fois ces problèmes résolus le
corsaire devint un des meilleurs
chasseurs de l'arsenal alliés il fut si
efficace qu'il fut construit jusqu'en
1952 et il fut largement employé lors de
la guerre de corée
[Musique]
mais l'entreprise la plus audacieuse de
cette guerre des porte avions eu lieu en
avril 1942 16 bombardier moyens b25
mitchell commandé par james doolittle
des colères du pont du ss hornet et
bombardèrent tokyo
le mitchell et est un des meilleurs et
des plus polyvalents bombardier moyen de
la guerre mais le faire décoller d'un
porte avions demandé à repousser
largement les limites de ses capacités
bien que l'attak de tokyo on ait eu
qu'un impact militaire minimes l'aspect
médiatique fut énorme les japonais
durant admettent que leur pays pouvait
être directement attaqués bien sûr le
raid des hommes de doolittle était
anecdotique mais il pouvait être certain
que lorsque des avions plus puissant et
mieux armés seraient disponibles les
destructions seraient terribles
[Musique]
entre temps la campagne de bombardements
en europe courant 1942 s'intensifiait
avec l'entrée en service de l'avre au
lancaster
[Musique]
le lancaster et est une évolution du
bimoteur manchester les rolls royce
vulture de ce dernier s'étant révélés
très peu fiable on les remplace à part
quatre merlas
[Musique]
l'avion ainsi transformé et rita non
seulement de l'énorme suta bombe du
manchester mais aussi de bien meilleures
performances
les langues casters jouèrent un rôle
essentiel tout au long des campagnes de
bombardements menés par la royal air
force et qui commença avec leur aide de
1000 bombardier contre cologne en mai
1942 même s'il restait encore des
problèmes avec la navigation et la
précision du bombardement le fait que la
royal air force et est capable d'envoyer
mille bombardier sur un objectif était
un message fort adressé aux allemands
même si ces bombardements n'ont pas
directement forcer les allemands à se
rendre ils ont causé d'énormes dommages
sur les productions militaires nazis et
ont monopolisé d'énormes ressources pour
défendre leur territoire
[Musique]
c'est raid de bombardiers franchir une
étape supplémentaire lorsque l'aviation
américaine arrivant en europe en 1942
avec en particulier la légendaire 8e air
force
deux jours les b 17 flying fortress et
les b 24 liberator était capable
d'atteindre leurs cibles de la baltique
à l'afrique du nord
pourtant au départ leurs pertes furent
énormes
les spitfire furent initialement envoyés
pour escorter ses bombardiers mais comme
il n'avait pas été conçu pour cela leur
autonomie était largement insuffisante
par conséquent les bombardier devait
survoler le territoire ennemi sans
escorte et sans protection
il était bien évidemment attendu par des
hordes de messerschmitt 109 et de
phoques wulf 190 dont certains étaient
équipés de roquettes
[Musique]
la solution pour les alliés était de
développer un avion d' attaques dont la
vitesse et l'altitude lui permettrait
d'échapper à la chasse allemande le dh
mosquito fut donc conçu dans ce seul but
il s'avéra si réussie qu'il fut ensuite
utilisé dans de nombreuses missions dont
la chasse de nuit et la reconnaissance
et bien sûr de nouveaux chasseurs
s'apprêtait à fondre sur l'allemagne
le premier d'entre eux fut le mustang
p-51 qui fit son premier vol en octobre
1940 le mustang fut conçue à la demande
de la royal air force son moteur allison
bien que disposant d'une grande réserve
de puissance à basse altitude
s'essoufflait dès qu'il fallait
rejoindre des niveaux de vol élevé le
problème fut résolu en remplaçant la
lisson là aussi par un rolls royce
merlin
les alliés disposaient alors du meilleur
chasseur de l'époque dont l'autonomie
lui permettait d'affronter l'ennemi
jusque dans ses derniers retranchements
et de gagner
pourtant les chasseurs à moteur à
pistons avait atteint l'apogée de leurs
règles les pilotes de chasse avait
parfois la surprise de sentir leur
commande se bloquer lors des pics et qui
leur faisait s'approcher de la vitesse
du son que seuls l'aérodynamique les
empêcher de franchir
on savait depuis longtemps qu'en théorie
il existait une vitesse qu'aucun avion à
moteur à pistons ne pourrait jamais
franchir
dès les années 30 franke whittle de la
royal air force avait conçu un nouveau
propulseur le réacteur
son invention était si radicalement
novatrices pour son époque qu'il fallut
attendre 1941 pour qu'un avion vole
enfin ainsi motorisé
[Musique]
le gloucester e28 n'était pourtant qu'un
avion expérimental et ce ne fut qu'en
juillet 1944 que les alliés
introduisirent leur premier chasseur à
réaction le gloucester météores
[Musique]
les premiers météores était juste un peu
plus rapide que les meilleurs chasseurs
conventionnelle et l'état-major n'était
pas encore certain du bien fondé de
cette formule
mais lorsque les premières bombes
volantes 9 et 1 comment certes a frappé
londres le météore trouva immédiatement
sa vocation il était capable de se
rapprocher des v1 et de les descendre au
canot ou de les déstabiliser du bout de
l'ale pour les projeter ainsi au sol
les dernières versions du météore sur
des moteurs plus puissants et ils servir
au sein de la royal air force jusque
dans les années 60 et furent largement
exporté vers d'autres armées de l'air si
la royal air force n'avait pas été aussi
réticentes au départ du projet
les britanniques auraient pu avoir la
première force aérienne à introduire un
jet dans son arsenal mais il avait été
devancé par les allemands
car deux mois avant l'entrée du service
du météore la luftwaffe avait reçu ses
premiers messerschmidt 262
[Musique]
le développement du 262 fut handicapée
par la pénurie de matières premières de
qualité due aux reds alliés et parce que
la priorité avait été donnée à une
version bombardier peu efficace qui ne
pouvaient emporter que deux petites
bombes
mais le 262 était un avion remarquable
sur bien des points
il fut le premier avion doté d'elle en
flèche doté de becs de bord d'attaqué et
d'une profondeur monobloc il est
l'archétype des chasseurs moderne
après-guerre l'influencent des
ingénieurs allemands fut très grande aux
usa nombre d'entre eux continuèrent leur
carrière après guerre dans l'industrie
aérospatiale américaine
leurs connaissances et leurs expériences
furent mises à profit par les
constructeurs américains pour développer
de nouveaux chasseurs du f91 aile droite
au f 86 à elle en flèche dans les deux
années qui ont suivi la fin du conflit
le f 86 sabre fut sans doute le meilleur
chasseur de sa génération grâce à ses
ailes en flèche sa puissance et son
armement pourtant hérité des chasseurs
de la seconde guerre mondiale son
aérodynamique qui lui permettait de
frôler la vitesse du son
en 1950 la guerre éclata en corée pour
la première fois des combats aériens
entre jet eurent lieu lorsque les f 86
rencontrèrent les mythes 15 de
construction russe
le mic ans comme le sabre était un
monomoteur à elle en flèche il fut
livrée en grande quantité aux alliés des
soviétiques
bien que le mic et des performances très
proches de celles du sabre il fut
cependant largement dominé les pilotes
américains est tant mieux entraînées et
plus expérimentés
le 6 août 1945 le monde entra dans l'ère
nucléaire lorsque le b 29 enola gay
l'achat une bombe atomique sur la ville
d'hiroshima
trois jours plus tard une seconde bombe
fut lancée sur nagasaki
ces deux terribles bombardements
nucléaires entraînèrent les japonais a
demandé la cessation des hostilités et
donc la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale en seulement quarante ans
depuis le vol des frères wright l'avion
avait progressé du stade de la machine
juste capable d'emporter un homme sur
une centaine de mètres en une arme
capable de dévaster une ville à des
milliers de kilomètres la puissance
aérienne devenait larmes stratégique par
excellence
les années qui ont suivi ont vu le monde
entier entrer dans la guerre froide les
américains et leurs alliés d'un côté les
nations communiste dominé par l'union
soviétique de l'autre
chacun développe à des armes nucléaires
et les avions capables de les emporter
les premiers bombardiers à réaction de
l'ère nucléaire ne possédait pas
d'armement défensif comptant sur leur
grande vitesse et leur haute altitude
pour échapper à leurs adversaires aux
usa le boeing b 47 devint le premier
bombardier stratégique à réaction
la force v fut créée pour doter
l'angleterre d'une force de dissuasion
dans les années 50
l'avion aux formes les plus remarquables
fut l'avro vulkan et son énorme aile
delta ses quatre réacteurs rolls royce
était capable de lui faire approcher la
vitesse du son est d'atteindre une
altitude de 20 mm
dans le même temps aux usa beau indh et
voilà le puissant des 52
il a été conçu pour transporter les plus
lourds de bombes sur des distances
intercontinental et pour cela il était
propulsé par huit réacteurs pratt &
whitney
le b52 fut une telle réussite qu'il est
encore en service alors que ses
contemporains sont depuis longtemps dans
des musées il constituera un élément
important des forces stratégiques
américaines jusqu'au milieu du 21e
siècle
[Musique]
en 1960 le b52 a été rejoint par le b 58
à fleurs construit par general dynamics
leurs fleurs fut le premier vrai
bombardiers supersoniques capable de
voler à deux fois la vitesse du son
[Musique]
à ce stade les bombes nucléaires était
essentiellement des développements des
armes employées à la fin du conflit dans
le pacifique elle devait être
impérativement largué plus ou moins
directement sur l'objectif
mais de nouvelles armes plus autonome
était déjà en développement
blue steel a été développée comme le
premier missile nucléaire aéroportée
britannique en attendant que le modèle
plus petit sky bolt soit disponible
[Musique]
sky bolt était un projet mené en commun
entre les britanniques et les américains
mais ces derniers se retirèrent du
programme les anglaises se révèle
incapable de continuer les projets sol
et donc blue steel demeura la seule arme
de dissuasion jusqu'à l'entrée en
service du missile polaris lancé depuis
des sous marins
pendant les années 50 l'altitude et est
considéré comme le plus efficace des
moyens de défense des aéronefs
conçu pour la cia dans le plus grand
secret le lookheed u2 était capable
d'atteindre 30 mille mètres d'altitude
il pouvait en toute impunité survoler le
territoire soviétique et il mener ses
missions d'espionnage
mais en 1960 les soviétiques réussira à
battre un u2 mise à part la perte d'un
avion top secret cet événement révéla
que les russes avaient développé des
missiles sol air et un système de radars
qu'ils ne garantissaient plus l'altitude
commune sécurité
[Musique]
de même les chasseurs ça remet
progressivement d'armes de plus en plus
puissante pour venir à bout des
bombardiers
cet étang des problèmes soulevés par la
guerre de corée les chasseurs avaient
besoin d'un armement de plus en plus
lourd par exemple le met 15 pouvait tiré
20 obus de 23 mm à la seconde le rockeur
hunter qui arriva trop tard dans la
royal air force pour participer à la
guerre de corée pouvait tirer 160 au but
par seconde grâce à ses quatre canons
haden et ce n'était pas encore assez
pour garantir la destruction d'un
bombardier chargé d'une bombe atomique
les années 50 et 60 vire l'avènement du
missile air air capable de se
verrouiller sur sa cible il y avait
plusieurs solutions un guidage par radar
ou le verrouillage sur la chaleur émise
par les réacteurs des avions
la royal air force développer un nouveau
système de défense complet et qui
exigeait de nouveaux avions et deux
nouveaux missiles
le glyphe électrique lightning fut le
premier chasseur britannique
supersonique
son rôle était intercepter les
bombardiers soviétique avant qu'il
n'arrive à portée de leurs cibles en
volant à deux fois la vitesse du son il
permettait d'avoir un temps de réaction
plus efficace une fois le bombardier
identifier formellement le pilote
pouvait tiré son missile capable de
détruire un bombardier en un seul coup
les lightnings comme l'art contemporain
avec une autonomie limitée et n'en
portait aucune autre arme on pensait que
l'époque du combat tournoyant était
révolue
le ravitaillement en vol cependant avait
été expérimenté en angleterre le rayon
d'action et d'autonomie de ces chasseurs
a un coût celui du coup largement
améliorée à la fin du xxème siècle
certains avions étaient donc capable de
parcourir le globe sans avoir à atterrir
l'âge du réacteur enfanta une nouvelle
ère également pour l'aviation civile
elle s'était déjà développé entre les
deux guerres mondiales mais la seconde
lui avait fait marquer un coup d'arrêt
les avions comme le douglas dc3 avait
participé au succès de quelques lignes
régulières juste avant le conflit
innovant en matière de confort pour les
passagers cet avion était apprécié pour
son chauffage et son isolation sonore
pendant la guerre le dc3 fut adapté pour
le transport militaire
des milliers furent construits et furent
employées sur tous les théâtres
d'opérations après la guerre le dc3
devint la cheville ouvrière de
l'aviation commerciale renaissante
l'expérience militaire incita les
constructeurs à se pencher sur des
projets d'avions disposant d'une plus
grande autonomie
le lockheed constellation joua un rôle
fondamental sur les lignes trans
océanique dans l'immédiate après guerre
[Musique]
en grande bretagne le vickers viscount
devient le premier avion utilisant un
moteur à mi chemin entre le réacteur et
le moteur à pistons le turbopropulseur
[Musique]
le marché du voyage aérien était en
pleine expansion alors qu'en 1952 arriva
le premier jet de ligne le 2 haviland
comète qui effectua sa première liaison
commerciale entre l'angleterre et
l'afrique du sud quelques semaines plus
tard boeing présentait le 707 l'époque
des jets intercontinentaux débutait le
voyage à bord de jets étaient déjà
présenté au grand public comme
indissociable des vacances
le terme jet set résume l'aspect glamour
du voyage aérien un terme encore utilisé
50 ans plus tard
aujourd'hui la demande est telle pour
les loisirs ou les affaires que les
constructeurs proposent de large gamme
d'avions conçu pour les différentes
exploitations possible prenons le cas de
l'airbus a320 cet avion est conçu pour
les liaisons courtes et moyennes telles
qu'on les trouve à travers l'europe à
l'autre bout de la gamme se trouve
l'airbus a340 série 500 ou 600 conçu
pour les vols très longs courriers
[Musique]
à
l'autre bout de la gamme se trouve
l'airbus a340 série 500 ou 600 conçu
pour les vols très long courriers
plus de 300 passagers peuvent être ainsi
transporter confortablement sans escale
sur près de 15000 kilomètres
il y à 50 ans lorsque le comedd
desservait l'afrique du sud de telles
performances avait tout du rêve
irréalisable
[Musique]
la demande pour des vols de moins en
moins chère font que des avions de plus
en plus rapide de plus en plus
confortable et de plus en plus énormes
vont bientôt sillonner notre ciel
l'a380 qui doit entrer en service fin
2006 sera capable de transporter sur ses
deux ponts plus de passagers qu'aucun
d'autres appareils en dépit de sa taille
il sera plus silencieux et plus
économique que les appareils de la
génération précédente
[Musique]
e
en 1969 concorde le premier avion de
ligne supersonique vola pour la première
fois véritable chef-d'oeuvre
technologique le concorde fut un échec
commercial
et n'eut que deux clients british
airways et air france
les coûts d'exploitation de l'appareil
était telle qu'il fallut le retirer du
service
finalement il est resté plus de 25 ans
en service afin racé élégant et élancée
le concorde focaliser les regards et
était considérée comme une machine de
rêve et pas seulement par les passionnés
d'aviation
l'expansion des voyages aériens a
cependant un prix les capacités des
aéroports arrive à un point de
saturation les problèmes d'environnement
influe aussi beaucoup sur la conception
des nouveaux appareils qui se doivent
d'avoir de plus grandes performances
l'accessibilité du vol pose de nombreux
problèmes
le contrôle aérien doit gérer un trafic
de plus en plus dense et qui concerne
des centaines de milliers si ce ne sont
des millions de passagers chaque jour
tandis que l'aviation commerciale a
connu une expansion rapide dans les
années 60 et 70 l'aviation militaire
quant à elle a repoussé bien des limites
la guerre du vietnam pendant les années
60 a souligné l'importance des forces
aériennes tactique et la nécessité
d'armement plus efficace
le mcdonnell douglas f 4 phantom s'est
révélé l'un des avions les plus
puissants et les plus polyvalents jamais
construit non seulement capable de voler
à deux fois la vitesse du son il se
révéla excellent aussi bien dans l'art
de la reconnaissance que du combat
aérien
il était doté d'un radar capable
d'illuminer une cible aussi bien vers le
bac vers l'avant alors que les avions
précédent ne pouvait détecter leurs
objectifs que directement vers l'avant
à une époque où les missiles air air
donnait une nouvelle dimension au combat
aérien au delà de la portée visuelle des
pilotes une telle capacité s'avérer
vitale
mais ces avions bombarder de systèmes
technologiques de pointe pouvait amener
le pilote à saturation on a fait a donc
un second membre d'équipage chargé de la
navigation et du système d'armes
libérant ainsi le pilote à même de se
consacrer entièrement au pilotage de son
avion le fantôme a été utilisé par de
nombreuses aviation à travers le monde
et aussi par l'us navy l'air force et le
corps des marines
en angleterre le fantôme remplaça le
lightning le temps que son nouveau
chasseur multirôle le tornado entre en
service
le tornado existantes deux versions
défense aérienne et attaques
ce fut un projet complexe car ils
étaient menés par trois nations
l'angleterre l'allemagne et l'italie
chacun avait des exigences différentes
arriver à les intégrer dans un unique
modèle d'avion fut un véritable exploit
de collaboration
[Musique]
dans la bible
roche
[Musique]
les larges
mais tandis que la royal air force
attendait c'est tornado une nouvelle
génération de chasseurs prenait forme
aux usa
le premier d'entre eux fut le f 15 eagle
avant le f-15 a été conçu pour
surclasser tous ses adversaires
potentiels on l'espérait aussi
performant autant dans les combats à
distance qu'en combat rapproché
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le f-15 fut rapidement suivi par le f16
fighting falcon à l'origine pensait
comme un chasseur léger le f16 est
devenu l'un des plus brillants chasseur
multirôle
les aviations de 18 pays comprenant
l'ufr force utilisent le f 16 qui
devrait rester en service bien au delà
de 2030
non
[Musique]
avant
le f-15 et son alter ego embarqué le f
14 tomcat ont été conçus au temps de la
guerre froide pour relever le défi les
soviétiques ont mis en service des
chasseurs radicalement moderne le mig-29
fut le premier à entrer en service en
1985 cl en flèche très prononcé ces
réacteurs très puissant de nomique 29
des performances exceptionnelles
le mig-29 fut rejoint par le sukhoï 27
avec ces deux avions ont été tentées les
premiers essais de poussée vectorielle
avec des tuyères mobile la poussée des
réacteurs peut être orienté précisément
et ceci a pour résultat de donner une
exceptionnelle manoeuvrabilité à ses
avions destinés à la supériorité
aérienne
[Musique]
cependant le concept le plus
radicalement novateur de cette époque
est basé sur une nouvelle technologie
communément appelée furtivité en anglais
tills
le f 117 nighthawk entrée en service en
1983 a étonné le monde par ses lignes
angulaires le chasseur furtif f 117 est
l'un des plus efficaces avions d'attac
au monde car il est quasiment invisible
par les radars les angles de son
fuselage disperse les ondes radar tandis
que sa peinture spéciale absorbe les
rayonnements restants de même ces
réacteurs sont disposés de façon à ce
que leur chaleur soient dissipés afin de
réduire la signature infrarouge de
l'avion bien que subsonic le style a
démontré son efficacité à de nombreuses
reprises pendant la guerre du golfe de
1991 dans les balkans en afghanistan et
très récemment en irak
[Musique]
le développement ultime de cette
technologie furtive a abouti au b 2
spirit
toutes les leçons qui ont découlé de la
conception du f 117 ont été incorporés
dans ce bombardier stratégique
avec un prix unitaire proche du milliard
de dollars le p2 est l'avion le plus
coûteux de toute l'histoire de
l'aviation et seulement 21 exemplaires
ont été commandés
à partir de leurs bases dans le missouri
les b2 peuvent traverser la planète en
transportant jusqu'à 16 missiles de
croisière ou autant de bombes nucléaires
c'est une capacité qui rend cet avion
très efficace dans le cadre de la
dissuasion global puisqu'il est capable
de délivrer un armement extrêmement
destructeur sans que personne ne puisse
le savoir ni l'intercepter
mais l'emploi de ces avions est il
porteur d'avenir ou bien ces machines
sont elles trop précieuse pour être
risqué au combat en une centaine
d'années l'avion a connu un
développement considérable
en dépit de ses capacités de destruction
le vol a aussi eu des conséquences
positives en rendant les nations plus
proches les unes des autres en
favorisant les échanges internationaux
l'avion a participé à la compréhension
des hommes entre eux mêmes situé sur les
bords opposés du globe
[Musique]
mais peut-être que l'aboutissement de ce
grand rêve a été d'emmener l'homme dans
l'espace en 1969 seuls les américains
buzz aldrin et neil amstrong sont
devenus les premiers hommes à se poser
sur la lune cet événement a été le point
culminant d'une course qui a débuté en
1957 lorsque les russes ont réussi à
placer en orbite le premier satellite
artificiel le spoutnik en 1961 le russe
youri gagarine devint le premier homme
dans l'espace mais c'est le programme
américain apollo qui permit la conquête
humaine de la lune
en avril 1970 des millions de
spectateurs à travers toute la planète
ont retenu leur souffle en suivant
l'équipage d'apollo 13 ramené sur terre
leur vaisseau spatial endommagé
véritable odyssée courageuse ce fut
l'une des plus belles aventures humaines
[Musique]
bonjour
quatre missions suivi chacune augmentant
notre connaissance de la lune les fusées
apollo été conçu pour ne volez qu'une
seule fois ce qui les rendait
abominablement coûteuse
le concept d'un vaisseau spatial
réutilisable abouti en 1981 au premier
vol de la navette columbia
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la conquête spatiale a
étendu son horizon bien au delà de la
lune et vers les autres planètes du
système solaire
actuellement les vols habités vers ses
lointains horizons semblait impossible
tout autant que franchir la manche
pouvait sembler lettre il y à une
centaine d'années
à cette époque l'horizon humain était
limitée par la technologie
l'humanité savait que l'avion pourrait
lui permettre de voyager un peu plus
loin de voir au delà de la plus proche
collines ou survolée quelques kilomètres
d'océan mais un siècle plus tard nous
pouvons survolé la planète toute entière
non seulement nous pouvons communiquer
entre nous plus facilement mais nous
pouvons voir comment notre environnement
est touché par nos activités et nous
n'avons pour cela qu'à regarder vers le
bas les nouveaux engins spatiaux nous
ont rendus ceci possible et nous
permettront un jour d'explorer d'autres
parties de l'univers le volume 1 vers la
plus proche planètes du système solaire
semble encore un rêve impossible mais il
se réalisera un jour tout comme le rêve
de voler devenu réalité lorsque le 17
décembre 1903 wilbur et orville wright
se sont rendus sur la dune de kiel des
hommes pour leur rendez vous avec leur
destin et avec l'histoire
[Musique]
à